Ja, hello
This is Adam Smith calling from Nobelprize.org
Hi, Adam, hello.
Congratulations of course on the award of
the Nobel Prize.
Thanks, thanks.
May I ask just what you were doing when the
news came?
I was reading a paper actually, and going
through the details of a paper.
And, your initial reaction on hearing the
news?
It was a total surprise.
I couldn't believe it.
The first moment I thought it was perhaps
a hoax or so.
But I remembered the voice of Professor Normark,
and I realised there were other people around
and he said he would confirm by email, and
so it's serious.
First of all I couldn't really believe it.
But then I gradually realised that it's true.
And what was the first thing you did after
you'd received the news and found out that
it was true?
Ja, I read the paragraph that I wanted to
read to the end.
And then I called up my wife and tried to
reach some of the people who are close to
me.
But that's marvellous, that's true dedication,
staying with the paper.
I guess that's what makes you successful.
You defied conventional wisdom in thinking
that you could break the diffraction barrier.
What gave you the courage to try that?
I think it was inside.
So, I had realised that, that was my view
at least, that so much physics happened in
the 20th century that it is impossible that
there is no say phenomenon, or physical chemistry
phenomenon, that would allow you to overcome
the diffraction barrier that was coined in
1873 or so.
So I felt that there must be something, a
kind of phenomenon that leads you beyond the
barrier.
And so I got kind of convinced that there
must be something, and so I tried to find
something and eventually I found ways to overcome
that limit.
Clearly you are deeply passionate about science.
Do you consider science fun?
Yes, absolutely.
So I love to be a scientist.
I've always enjoyed being curious.
I've always enjoyed doing challenging things
and also challenging common wisdom.
So, I think that's something a scientist can
do because a scientist works at a border,
at the edge of science, at the edge of knowledge,
and so there's a lot of fun of reaching out
and thinking about things that other people
didn't think about.
And so it has a kind of exploratory notion,
kind of adventurous part in it.
I think people often neglect that, that really
you can be in the lab and be just as adventurous
as people exploring the deep ocean.
Absolutely, and also creative.
I mean, you can imagine that something works.
I imagined there would be a way to crack the
diffraction barrier.
But of course I didn't know exactly how it
would work, but I had a gut feeling that there
must be something and so I tried to think
about it, to be creative.
And that initial phase of the development,
it was a creative act.
In the end of course you have to prove that
it's not just imagination.
It's not just a theory or just a thought - it
is true.
And there is where the hard work comes in.
And you have to really prove that the way
you think about it is right.
And that took, of course, some time and a
lot of development.
Thank you very much indeed.
That's marvellous.
I guess now that you're going to be swamped
by people like me asking you questions.
How does that prospect?
Well, I locked myself in, and so I'm OK so
far.
How very sensible of you.
You sound like you're well in control of this
situation.
So, I wish you a very enjoyable day.
I hope the following hours are enormous fun.
Thank you very much for speaking to us now.
Thank you very much for calling.
My pleasure.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
Bye.